welcome to the emergency self-defense
class I'll be showing you how to escape
from a variety of situations while
inflicting maximum damage on your
attackers Ron do you think that maybe I
should put mark in a headlock that way I
can show everyone how to escape a
pervert in the scenario you just laid
out you're the pervert you understand
that right you wish enough I'm gonna
start off simple and demonstrate how to
extract oneself from a wrist grab Andy
and step up here I watched a lot of
Lifetime movies there was this one how
far is too far enough the Terry Paulo
Berlin Argon's story this woman had
agoraphobia and her therapist was
obsessed with her and he hid in her
house and then he attacked her and tried
to eat her toes also her daughter was
having sex way too young so yeah free
self-defense class I'm there I just
twisted yeah that was awesome
I was really good okay lesson learned
yeah impressive I'm going to engage Andy
in an attack hold he's gonna try and
break free cool now I don't hurt you run
don't worry about that just try to
escape my attack now when I get out am I
allowed to counter-strike sure when you
get out you may counter-attack but just
promise me you'll be ready because I
mean I don't want to destroy you oh okay
let's see what's going with this now
when your arms are pinned to your sides
use your legs to break free instead of
your neck which is when Andy's trying to
do Gilda yeah let him go
Andy Oh God oops okay what day is it
today I don't know okay but to be fair
you never know that's kind of true I'm
super bad at days but honestly I'm fine
sorry I squeezed your lights out there
son no worries will you show me how to
do that move though sure I can teach you
right now no no no Andy you should
really just take it easy I think she
wants more water or maybe some pancakes
no no I'm fine thank what's the first
move in any fight punch to the balls
you